so good morning everyone my day started
at 6:00
but I'm late anyway so in the end of my
talk I will sweat anyways because we
have a hardware demo of motion
prediction with acceleration and
rotation rates and we try to predict
with machine learning whether the device
is running sitting walking or going by
bike everybody of you who have an iPhone
gut since the last version m7 motion
processor and now the m8 motion
processor so your iPhone or probably
your Android smartphone is doing this
all the time measuring acceleration and
rotation rate and predicting if you are
running sitting or going by bike so most
important thing first I look later
because my daughter is at home and I had
my job too
this morning so short introduction video
m36 seconds so so the device I will show
you in the end of this talk in your
pocket and we will predict which
activity the person or the device is
doing so I don't know if everybody of
you are on Twitter and saw I posted a
link to code and stuff and everything
right from the bus means 20 minutes ago
so the code is on github and you can
download it afterwards it's it's no
basic machine learning talk so we are
not going into details how the
algorithms work it's all about feature
engineering you know the algorithms are
in talks all over the world you can look
at YouTube there are very good tutorials
so today we will talk about feature
and calculation to estimate what happens
with this device so let's dive into it I
am prepared a log file named activity
data but seems we I am created to fire
with my smartphone there's Enzo lock app
and I put it in my pocket and started
logging acceleration and rotation rates
and dumped it into log files and now I
have the labeled activities I had choose
for activities and lock them with 50
Hertz that's actually a good measurement
rate so here you will see the data the
devices are six degrees of freedom in
natural in inertial measurement units
that means you have acceleration in
three directions and you have rotation
rates around these three axes that's in
your smartphone that's on this device
it's from a tinkerer Forge German
company they say you are very good I am
you and Master brick to connect via USB
yes I am I started logging put the
smartphone in my pocket and drove with
my bike afterwards I labeled the fire
biking so I have these motion data with
labeled activities so it's supervised
learning we have some description for
everything not very descriptive but the
first feature I want to introduce is the
absolute acceleration that means you
don't need to get the orientation of the
device it doesn't matter in which
organization the devices in your pocket
or in your back or on the on the bike
and you have this simple calculation
take all three s0
patience and calculate the absolute
acceleration that's what I'm doing here
I'm calculating the absolute
acceleration of the data and here's our
first feature or hopefully a good
feature you see while sitting all the
devices in your pockets have absolute
accelerations like this that means 1g
that's yes serration towards the earth
the gravity is 1g so while sitting you
have an absolute acceleration of 1g
while walking it's a little bit messy
and while running you know when you run
you have high variance of the absolute
acceleration so maybe and I know it's
true so maybe it's a good feature to
estimate which of the four activities
the device is doing so we calculate we
calculate the difference of Max min with
rolling Max and rollin minutes panas I'm
using pandas most of the time so rolling
Max - rolling min of the absolute
acceleration and you can think about it
you have a hull high curve on on top and
on bottom and the difference between is
a difference of of the absolute
acceleration so that's that's the first
feature it looks like this so we're
sitting it's nearly zero walking running
nearly three and while biking it's one
something so if we if you take a look at
these features in scatterplot it's
looking like this so here you have
sitting means absolute acceleration of
1g and nearly no difference no variance
of the acceleration and
the green one is running but walking and
biking is in the middle and you can't
separate running and walking with this
feature so we need a second feature and
this is the rotation rate of the device
the rotation rate is looking like this
rotation rate means how fast the device
is turned
so no turning no rotation rate fast
turning high rotation rate so if you if
you take a look at these values while
walking it's looking like this and while
biking is looking like this
so you see you if you have your device
in your pocket and moving your your leg
periodically so you have to bike then
you see a periodic movement of the
rotation rate so and engineers in this
room know what to do is with periodic
signals you have the FFT algorithm you
can throw a value in and get a frequency
back so the FFT algorithm and he made it
so if you don't understand the f of T
this is the animation of it you have a
signal these are two mix signals the
group the green one is resulting and
think about your looking from the side
so you have the imaginary plane and look
from the side then you have the
amplitude and the frequency and this is
what FFT algorithm is doing if you need
code for F of T here it is and we fire
this FFT algorithm on the on the whole
data set on the whole rotation rate and
you see while biking you have here
something 2 or 3 Hertz means 2 or 3
times per second a high rotation rate
and while walking it's not the case so
that's the second and also most
important feature to separate all
activities and now we've done that or
you see you
is walking the the FFT amplitude peak in
radians per second so the rotation rate
yes
here you have walking and that's biking
so now we come to the machine learning
part that's where you guys are more more
professional but I did my best to to
work out how to estimate activities if
you plot the scatter of all of our two
just to have features it's like I told
the difference of absolute acceleration
and the FFT amplitude peak you see you
and actually this are two these are two
colors not on this beam up but on my
laptop these are two colors it's
probably biking and that's probably
walking so you see four clusters of four
classes of features for four different
activities looks like an easy one I
separated in labels and training data
and trained with I think to trained with
eighty percent so tested with twenty and
I'm using an SVC with linear kernel you
can do more magic but that's all I
understand and I know in every machine
learning talk there is the rule if the
accuracy score is 100 percent you did
something wrong I don't know if I I
don't know if I did something wrong I I
mean the the features are pretty
discriminant and the SVC algorithm and
so the the accuracy scores 100 percent
at least for my label data we will see
you there the real world example is not
100 percent accuracy accuracy score but
if I have to present this to my boss
it's a pretty good example you don't see
the description borders the decision but
on us
just because this is - yeah they are so
you see the SVC figured out some
decision boundless boundaries for every
activity so we developed a machine
learning algorithm to separate
activities based on our features so
let's save it and let's try a real
example I have here this fire tinker
life classification tinker because
that's the thing of watch sends our own
life because I'm now running as far as I
can and hopefully it will show you first
take let's take a look at so like I said
to think of watch mu I'm connecting to
it with some code I am loading I'm
loading the classifier we developed I
calculate the features from from the raw
sensor data the boast features here is
the fft amplitude peak and here's the X
acceleration max min def so two features
and I collect I collect sensor data
until I got one second one second of
signals because for the F of T you need
window size a specific window size to
calculate that 50 so I'm waiting once
one second and I have at 10 milliseconds
sample rate I have enough values to
calculate F of T and after that I'm
firing everything through the through
the predict step you see classifier that
that's the one I loaded predict with
this box features so
any questions so far because no I'm
trying to figure out we know it's all
right
so it's connecting it's connecting to
this device and you'd see them the
device is sitting and hopefully now so I
have to put it in my pocket because
that's where I measured examples so now
we feel the accuracy score isn't 100%
but I think sitting or standing wait a
second I thought so while I'm sitting or
standing
it should say sitting or selling while
I'm walking it will predict I'm walking
why I am running it hopefully predict I
ran harder last time
last time it was a hotter running are
the shoes other ground no running this
time because I'm actually not running so
it's pretty smart so on the the last one
is biking you see the movement of my leg
it's estimated as biking so not not
really 100% but if you look at your
Apple device in health it doesn't depict
every action you doing but nearly every
action is separated from each other so I
think a lot of questions because it's
engineering and not data science but you
know these two disciplines are matching
now because engineers trying data
science it's like me and and data
scientists cut jobs from real world
problems not just computer problems so
questions so far yes these no these
think of watch guys did a great job they
implemented a filter and better
performing better than a common filter
and you get the orientation of the
device filtered so not the rotation
rates or the acceleration but if you
need the orientation of the device its
filtered through a filter it's not a
common filter but something like that
yes and it's implemented on hardware you
can get it brrp so I think approach does
a good job on that what
yes um you know if you are on healthcare
site and you want to know if the person
got a loan living person got a problem
so walk walking then sitting or laying
on the ground
no movement then you then you have to
estimate the state of the person so
that's the that's the easy part
separated your grandma is biking or
running or walking or sitting and the
harder part is detect if the person is
laying on the ground or slipping or
falling to the ground something like
that so these are only four states four
states you can imagine you have some
more states to predict in real life you
know how fast can you change your
activity as a human and I thought okay
the the FFT algorithm cuts better if the
window size is longer so if you just
have one point or one point zero one
second then you just have ten values and
you have to calculate the F of T with
just ten values it's it's probably
inaccurate then for sure for sure for
sure
empirically you choose like yes that's
right so I figured out the one-second
window size is a very good very good
data time for activity change for humans
because if from biking to walking it
takes one or two seconds and so you
don't need this more of them I can
reduce it to 1.0 seconds then it's
digitated but it's no information gain
you can have it on your wrist or
somewhere else it's probably more
difficulty to esthar get the state um
I think ever got the states from the
iPhone and your health data from the
watch so I don't think that they can
estimate everything from your wrist but
I think there are good features to
estimate you know you have to move your
your arms so you can estimate some
states from from wrist and as far as I
know health care devices are on on don't
know the word chest on your are on your
chest or on your wrist and they try to
figure out what your activity is or are
you laying sitting something like that
so it's possible but I think with other
features or some more features we just
had to just me so that's eventually why
it's for sopia separation yes yes
because it's a yeah it's the easy part
I just took the clear part you know if
you have you go on the bike and jumping
over rocks and something that you have
you have different features so it's not
this easy for off-road biking or
something like that so I made it easy
that the accuracy score is 100%
yeah no no breaking no acceleration
while biking I sing highest I started
logging drove bike five minutes stop
clogging and named the fire biking no I
got I I looked for different log files
I started logging drove bike stopped
save the file name biking then started
logging running safe to fire running so
the labels are and you can see how I
made the data you have here in the data
set prep data iPad notebook
and there you can see the magic eye
I read all log files and got the name
from the label for the activity from the
file name so
you
you